nothing in portugal stands out quite
like the vibrant colors and unusual
architecture of penner palace
[Music]
henna national palace is located within
western portugal's sintra mountains
although the palace's varied design
choices make it appear as though it has
been built from multiple pieces of
different castles the building's unusual
style is the result of an owner with
extremely flamboyant tastes
[Music]
the palace was owned by king ferdinand
ii who built it to serve as a summer
home for portuguese royals in the late
18th century
the castle itself is built around an old
monastery and is made up of coloured
sections including a red clock tower and
a yellow minaret
during the revolution of 1910 the royals
fled and the palace and its grounds were
abandoned
it wasn't until the 20th century that it
was restored by the state and earned
itself a unesco heritage site
designation
king ferdinand's wide-ranging tastes
have made penner palace a microcosm for
all the styles of architecture the world
has to offer
[Music]